the US government is getting some
criticism in the race to respond to this
crisis the CDC is accused of botching
the initial rollout of testing kits and
not getting more Americans tested for
the corona virus sooner than Tracy's at
the White House where President Trump is
saying not to worry then good morning
this would be a challenge for any leader
what is the president's next step well
the president was supposed to visit the
CDC in Atlanta today but he has now
canceled that trip he is expected to
sign that eight billion dollar emergency
spending bill that will help fund an
eventual vaccine and more testing but
there are still a lot of questions just
about how many tests are available and
who can actually get tested everybody
has to become it's all going to work out
on Fox News Thursday night President
Trump once again downplayed the threat
of coronavirus and complemented his
administration's response I think people
are viewing us as having done a very
good job but Congress is already
investigating the slow roll out of
coronavirus testing kits that are just
now reaching labs across the country in
Minnesota Thursday while visiting a
company that makes protective face masks
the vice president acknowledged a
shortfall in the number of kits
available we don't have enough tests
today to meet what we anticipate will be
the demand going forward on Wednesday
pence made this estimate roughly 1.5
million a test that will be available
this week yesterday Health and Human
Services secretary Alexander each person
needs more than one test by the end of
the week we believe we'll have shipped
74 75 thousand people to be tested a
czar added that a private company would
be able to provide material for another
400,000 people to be tested so this week
roughly less than half a million people
could actually be tested the mixed
messaging has frustrated lawmakers like
patty Murray from Washington State which
has been fighting the deadliest
outbreaks of the virus in the US
I am deeply concerned that I do not have
the trust in this administration right
now the state's governor jay Inslee has
been fiercely critical of president
Trump's handling of the virus response
but he sounded hopeful
after a meeting with the vice president
I want to focus today on the work we
need to do at a partnership and I can
tell you that I think that this is a
good partnership moving forward the
White House is pushing back on reports
that Health and Human Services Secretary
Alex azar has been sidelined he's been
criticized for the slow initial response
to the virus
he was noticeably absent during the vice
president's trip yesterday and a
briefing here at the White House earlier
this week Anthony Ben thank you